morning everyone for better or worse I
hear you're stuck with me so I'm glad i
work at fiscal note which is a DC based
startup that focuses on all sorts of
legal data and today i'll be talking
about insights into and methods for
analyzing legislation across the u.s. so
you're probably all familiar with the
success of data-driven methods in
politics or specifically for politicians
where especially in the obama campaign's
in the last two there was a lot of
computational methods being leveraged to
really target the right voters and
really get the right resources the right
people to knock on the right 40 doors to
have the most impact and also in being
able to accurately forecast how the
election is going to turn out so here
we're interested in taking a similar
sort of computational analysis but
turning it back on to government so how
can we uncover what's going on
government where things are happening
what's happening and what issues that we
might be able to influence as they're
going on so the government releases a
massive amount of data but a lot of its
structured so its economic forecast its
unemployment numbers its crop outlook
and there's a lot of developed and
applied methods in using statistics and
modeling to kind of approach that data
but most of that the statistics is
driven by the policy the legislation
regulations in general the legislative
climate that made the employment
possible or the taxes so how can we get
at that unstructured data what's going
on in the legislation in the regulations
and use the same type of computational
approaches to try to understand that so
the goal is to really gain insight into
what's going on in government by
leveraging all this unstructured data
and making it useful making it such that
we can provide actionable insights both
to organizations and to the public so
there's a couple different levels of
legal data first there's legislation
which will be focusing on here and then
that leads to development of regulations
and then eventually if legislation
passes they become statutes and then
eventually if there's any sort of
problems there's case law but here we'll
just focus on the first
so a couple motivating examples so a
state has a lot trillions of dollars in
fact across the u.s. depending on taxing
and spending so a lot of the states have
been starting to introduce marketplace
ference acts which would tax online
spending so Erin sales which would mean
that there is either billions of dollars
more revenue for the state or less
revenue for the company so every company
that operates and more than one state
has to keep track of these things and
know where to focus their resources
similarly on an individual level most
states have been starting to introduce
minimum wage laws but only 13 so far has
actually raised the wages so as an
individual you might have decisions to
base on what state climates are looking
like where you should work and in
general we can try to answer questions
like why do some states have a much
better environment for being able to
raise wages or as others that languages
so the point I'm trying to drive is that
legislation is very important for all
sorts of decision making but it's very
hard to get at what's going on inside of
it most of the analysis happening now is
very qualitative and it's not just
manual effort that can be crowd-sourced
its policy expert domain expert driven
manual effort which is very time
intensive and human capital intensive so
the question for us is how can we assist
that effort computationally how can we
provide tools insight and do some of the
heavy lifting in order for people to do
what people do best which is provide
their own insight on top of what we have
so the way we'll go about is gathering
as much data as we can which we'll talk
about first and then applying a suite of
NLP tools in machine learning to try to
gain insight into what's going on and to
how to make decisions based on that so
first let's take a look at the actual
data so there's one federal government
but don't let that fool you it produces
a ton of data and it's very important
even though there's not much going on
now anything that does go on is still
hugely important and impactful for
everyone then there's 50 state
governments plus DC there's around 3,000
county governments and almost
19 and a half municipal governments all
of them producing legislation all of
them impacting both people and
organizations so going down to the
numbers the first thing so this is a
graph of legislation introduced over the
last five years in all of the states
across the u.s. so the first thing you
probably noticed is that legislators
have a pretty nice healthy summer
vacation from july to january there's
not much going on and you'll also notice
that it's very cyclical in nature even
so that every odd year there's more
legislation being introduced than even
yours because some legislators only meet
every other year so on a busy day
there's between 10 to 20,000 or on a
week sorry there's between ten and
twenty thousand pieces of legislation
being introduced which all needs to be
in is so drilling down even further on a
month-by-month basis we can see that
from the up to 140,000 bills introduced
each year most come from january to
march so that means all of the human
effort really has to be centralized in
those three months to try to understand
what's important what's not where are
things going so going down on the state
level probably not surprisingly we can
see the distribution of where most
legislation is introduced we have New
York leading the way and then some
states that probably makes sense like
Texas Illinois and then some probably
you wouldn't have thought of like
Tennessee possibly New Jersey because of
its size that also introduced a lot of
legislation that are very regulation
heavy and people and corporations and
organizations have to be wary of what's
going on there and what kind of data is
this isn't nice big human-generated or
sr a user generated machine readable
data it's noisy hard to get why is this
still on a floppy disk kind of data so
there's a lot of effort even though
there's only one or two slides here that
goes on for us and trying to aggregate
it normalize it check it and make sure
it's clean enough and usable enough that
we can actually build any sort of
analysis on top of it or present it to
anyone so there's a couple problems even
when we do have access to the data first
of all it's quite stale so we're
depending on the states to publish
what's important what's going on and if
they don't publish it quite free
we have to go about in other ways trying
to get their their audio feed trying to
do some audio function on it trying to
get it through other sources so stay on
this is a very important factor when
you're doing with day by day hour minute
by minute issues a lot of its incomplete
if we're trying to assess lobbying
efforts going on a lot of that is dark
it's dark my needs in back rooms it's
not registered lobbyists so how do we
account for that in our modeling effort
to try to assess what impact that's
going to have and then some of its just
inaccurate so we need to check it across
different sources so we have a whole
infrastructure in place to aggravate the
state it continuously check it and flag
it and then send it off for QA if need
be but that's a very time and processing
intensive process on a good side there's
lots of open data initiatives that are
starting to pop up that are publishing
this data cleaner more frequently and
are really helping the community in the
public and getting this out there so
assuming we have this data we get to the
fun part so what can we do with it so a
couple things will focus on here is
first we can start answering some basic
political science questions or just
aggregate questions on high level what's
going on we can start discovering trends
our state's in flowing into each other
how our issues spreading through the
u.s. what kind of issues are arising and
then we can even forecast outcomes how
we think a piece of legislation is going
to fail and what's important so first
you might think that all the states
provide nice categories of what the
actual legislation is doing you would be
wrong so what we have to do is normalize
we create our own taxonomy and then we
have a set of machine learning
supervised on super unsupervised
clustering and classifiers that go
through the data and try to put it all
into one hierarchical taxonomy and then
we can label every category that we
think is pertinent and then once we do
that on a high level we can start asking
so what's going on what are the broad
issues that legislators across the u.s.
I've been focusing on so not
surprisingly labor and employment legal
affairs which is all sorts of courts
legislation then health families and
children education and taxes that makes
sense we can just check that and then
can compare it to on an individual state
basis what estates focusing on is there
any interesting differences between on
an aggregate ski on specific state so
for instance in Washington we notice
transportation moved up to the third
spot so that's a good starting point for
some exploratory data analysis to say
well what are they having transportation
initiatives that we should pay attention
to or in New York cry move up to the
second spot which probably makes sense
there's a lot of crime initiatives so as
in crime they've been quite successful
so this is a good jumping off point for
someone with political science
experience to go and say let me dig
deeper so then that's an aggregate view
of all the legislation but how effective
are the states is actually passing the
legislation so here we have a bar chart
on the x-axis we have every state going
from most successful on the right to be
successful of how much of the
legislation they've introduced actually
gets enacted so not surprisingly us
actual Congress is on the left side with
around two percent and then if we go
over to the right side we have Georgia
Arkansas Louisiana North Dakota Texas
they're all passing a good part over
fifty percent of their legislation of
all the legislation that they introduced
but then what if we have sorry that's
all of it but that's including a lot of
resolutions a lot of what's name this
post office that or commemorating this
guy so what if we just limited to actual
bills that are trying to accomplish
something difficult well then we see
what a different picture we noticed that
a lot of states are padding their stats
so Georgia drops down quite
significantly so to a high on Texas both
on the right from significantly
accomplishing a lot of things to
basically only having a few and it
creates a an interesting jumping off
point to understand what the way to
state of climate is in each state so
then what if we want to track issues
discover what's arising in the states
and how they're influencing each other
so here on the left side we have a a
graph of the frequency of issues so we
try to cluster very granular lee and
identify certain issues that are
spreading through the US so this one is
about fracking and then you
different color represents a state and
the x-axis is again the time so this
one's very clean we see first New Jersey
in 2011 introduces a lot of legislation
about fracking which is quite
interesting because there's no fracking
in New Jersey there won't be for a long
time but they're trying to establish a
certain precedent politically and it
seems to have had an impact because then
in the next year we see Pennsylvania and
Ohio both introducing a lot of
legislation a lot of activity around
that and then the next year and filters
over to Illinois and then next year we
see a lot more activity going back to
the east we have new hampshire maryland
jersey so this is a very nice example of
how this issue is going through the
legislators and it's not necessarily
cause well it's not that one's
influencing another that's something of
an open research problem for us to
identify how we think influence is going
on but it's just an interesting trend
that points in a good direction so
another one is same-sex marriage so this
one isn't as queen in terms of state by
state but in aggregate we see a lot more
activity starting to go on as the years
progress in a lot more states and in a
broad level we see the east coast states
leading the way and then the Midwestern
states starting to catch up in that
respect and this might look a little
different from what you're used to
because a lot of states didn't have
legislative initiatives for same-sex
marriage but more public and ballot
initiatives and that's why you're not
seeing what you might have expected here
so that's all about the actual bill is
the legislation but bills are created by
people and people have certain
relationships certain influences certain
beliefs so to really get at why certain
legislation is introducing why its
effect over y pasas we need to start
thinking about what are the social
relationships between these people what
do they care about so in order to do
that we construct social graphs of
legislators of elected officials then
issues they care about those they
introduce certain external information
such as lobbying efforts any sort of
organizational ratings of them and other
sources to try to construct a more
complete picture of these individuals
and get a graph based on what we think
they're going to think about a certain
issue or
for what they're going to vote on a
certain bill so then once we do that we
can start creating cool pictures like
this one which isn't quite as useful
from an analysis standpoint but it gets
that a bit of the picture so in the
House of Representatives without making
any statements about partisanship on the
right side you see a lot more points
isolated by themselves without as many
connections to the others and then a lot
of internal connected points so each one
representing a legislator in the House
of Representatives and their connections
through issues to the other legislators
but then using this graph and doing some
dimensionality reduction on one of the
accesses perhaps we can verify something
we've been hearing a lot about which is
that partisanship is on the rise so
we've heard that Congress is divided so
can we bear this out with the data well
it turns out if we collapse that graph
on one dimension just focusing on the
left side of the screen for now we have
the house of representatives in each
point represents a legislate or the blue
ones Democrats the red ones Republicans
and we can see that in the 111th
Congress on top the points are much
closer together with each black line
indicating the mean ideological position
of where we think those people are and
then as we progress down to the hundred
thirteenth congress we see this point
spreading out quite significantly we see
the left shifting and the right shifting
entails developing on either side so the
Senate picture presents much of the same
view with ideological centers shifting
and people spreading further apart and
that's just based on doing some
dimensionality reduction on social graph
that we built just off the data
available to us so then lastly can we
try to actually forecast how we think a
piece of legislation is going to fare so
it's not quite like you saw in school of
rock there's a lot of steps involved
this is a flowchart from Virginia of how
legislation actually becomes a law but
since we like approximating things we're
just approximated with this simpler
chart so first the bill is introduced
then it's referred to committee it might
get out of the committee it might be
reported favorably or unfavorably and
then if it does it might be picked up by
the speaker and considered on the floor
and if it
might get a vote and in my pass and if
that happens it'll go on to the second
chamber so we break this whole process
down into four stages two in each of the
chambers and the first one is how likely
is the bill together the committee and
actually get to a floor vote and then
the second is if it gets to a four vote
how likely is it actually pass so can we
do this and it turns out we can actually
do this quite accurately and so for
every bill we provide a forecast of how
we think it's going to fare admin this
is a separate topic but we try to
visualize what the reasons behind it are
so transforming machine learning
features into human interpretable very
easily digestible output is something of
an interesting problem so we provide
that and then we try to provide how we
think every way just wait or is going to
vote on a certain issue so how do we do
this so we take all the data and all the
analysis that I talked about previously
all the legislative information the
relationships the external information
and then we try to put it together in a
host of different models to try to
predict at each stage on different
issues how we think things are going to
turn out so the reason we have all these
different models is because that
behavior is quite different at different
stages so here we have just a small
sample of the states with the percentage
of passage on the left and first we'll
start with the red which is how likely
is the bill to get a committee to a
floor vote and you see all of those are
quite low from five to ten percent to
about forty percent at the highest and
then the blue is assuming it did get out
of committee and got a floor vote how
likely is it actually to pass and that's
much higher so the main takeaways that
once things get to the floor they're
probably going to pass most of the time
over forty percent but the hard part the
bottleneck is getting that the committee
so that needs to be modeled very
carefully and so the distributions from
some of our models are here and you can
see that they're quite different some of
them have a long tail depending on the
stage there in the state some of the
more uniform a lot of things pass some
are sort of in between but there's a lot
of nuances that go on a lot of issues
that have to be taken to an account and
it's quite an interesting problem so the
main takeaways here are that legislative
information
although it might not be the first thing
to come to your mind is actually quite
crucial for decision making but for
people and for organizations and it's
hard to get it's very noisy is
unstructured it's not always very easily
accessible but once you have it there
are some really cool things you can do
with data analysis and start answering
some questions that might lead to really
interesting research problems which I've
touched on here a bit but I'd love to
talk more about if anyone's interested
thank you